move to approve and a second all right all in favor aye opposed abstention motion
carries 4-0 consent calendar anybody wish to pull any items or have questions on
items okay any other ones okay I have questions on DNE so why don't we approve
the balance minus DNE just want to remind you that on 13 F which is the
resolution of denial for the I-15 self-storage project the resolution being
recommended for approval is the one in the supplemental staff report and the
differences please clarify there were some additional clarifying findings that
were made strengthening the decision to deny okay very good so with that we will
I'll ask for a motion to approve all except D and E with the substituted
resolution in item F let's approve have a second all in favor for those aye opposed
abstention motion carries item D I wanted to ask on this one